we begin with the major new developments
in China's coronavirus outbreak two
major cities are now under lockdown as
china races to contain the mysterious
illness that has killed at least 17
people another city is shutting down all
their train stations quarantine orders
affect more than 18 million Chinese
citizens the virus has infected nearly
600 people in at least six countries
including the US where a second possible
case was reported overnight in Los
Angeles Ramey Inocencio is in Beijing he
left Wuhan the epicenter of this
outbreak just before they closed off the
city Ramey what about the one confirmed
u.s. victim good morning that's right
health officials in Washington State say
that man flew here to China to Wuhan
province visited and then flew back home
now Airport screenings those have become
stronger since then take a look at this
video because you can actually see our
own CBS news team landing back in
Beijing from Wuhan ourselves and then
getting temperature checked by officials
right off the plane such interesting
stuff there but critics they are now
saying that China's move to try to
isolate nearly 20 million people may
just be too late disinfection point this
was a scene inside Wu Hans International
Airport yesterday just before we boarded
our flight you could see nearly every
person wearing a mask in the terminal
but today it'll look more like a ghost
town along with the main train station
Wu Hans eleven million people are being
told they can't leave a major step into
cities and countries fight against this
virus we stressed to them by having a
strong action not only they will control
the outbreak in their country but they
will also minimize the chances of this
outbreak spreading internationally that
follows several global health guidelines
Wuhan is an acting doctors covered
head-to-toe and a quarantine of ground
zero we visited before leaving it's
closed and shuttered now and there's a
heavy security presence we got out
earlier to take a look and an officer
ordered really yelled at us to leave in
the US the country's first infected
patient is recovering at a Washington
Hospital
health officials say he's in good
condition but concerned about his
contact with others as of now there are
at least 16 identified close contacts
local health department's started
reaching out to them yesterday dr. Jorge
Diaz admitted him to the hospital Monday
night he spoke to our Carter Evans about
how they're treating him the robot that
we're using has access to a special
stethoscope which lets me listen to the
patient's lungs heart etc I do an exam
and the World Health Organization
reconvenes today to decide whether to
call this epidemic a global health
emergency but looking ahead it's unsure
what really is going to happen because
these are just early days yet before
what could be a global crisis Tony yeah
and for scale there that city in China
is about the size of New York City where
the restrictions are now taking place
Remy innocencio for us in Beijing Randi
thank you very much